this is our beds here this is our food
this is our how we sleep John has named
this blue canopy bucks House Hotel and
it's got quite a view he put it up last
Thursday 10 days before the big day
I'll see for my own eyes accommodation
when I see that they'll both be wearing
crowns that's my most point moment with
the coronation it will also be the
highlights for his neighbors Marie and
Patrick who have splurged on the
memorabilia it's all used to make you
can dream up as a royal fan that
atmosphere the camaraderie with people
um it's just going to be magical there
is a sense of community it is it really
is it's just sort of we all love the
same thing and we just live and breathe
it these Royal super fans will have the
best view of the processions and of the
moment that King Charles appears at the
balcony at Buckingham Palace but they
won't get to see the crowning moment
itself at Westminster Abbey that is the
hottest ticket in town
especially is that only 2 200 of them
some 6 000 fewer than the late Queens
among them a TV royalty Anton Decker
invited his princess trust ambassadors
as a Lionel Richie and the editor of
British Vogue Edward Enfield and there's
only one answer to the RSVP I think
they're going to really think they've
they've hit the jackpot because this is
going to be a really remarkable service
some coronations in the past don't I'm
not talking about 1953 but you know the
Georgian kings that kind of thing people
could actually buy a ticket
um they could purchase one
if only that were the case for this
group it is their dedication and food
and blankets that will get them to the
weekend they're in no doubt it'll be
worth the wait Ash Sky News on the mount